good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight so when a Tulsi gabbard
won the Democratic party's primary for
congressional seat in Hawaii 10 years
ago she'd effectively won the seat
Hawaii may be the most liberal out of
all 50 states it is a democratic State
flat out it is not voted for Republican
presidential candidate in nearly 40
years
so if you get elected as a democrat in
Hawaii it's not exactly breaking news
it's standard operating procedure and
yet when Tulsi gabbard won that primary
and then the seat the Democratic
National Party took a deep interest in
her and you can see why here was a smart
appealing 31 year old who knew what she
believed and could explain it fluently
and by the way she was also in a rock
war veteran so in political terms Tulsi
gabbard was near perfect and they got it
immediately Barack Obama endorsed her
right away Nancy Pelosi called her
personally and invited Tulsi gabbard did
you remember this to speak on the
opening night of the Democratic National
Convention and then when she was sworn
into Congress in January the DNC named
Tosi gabbard Vice chair of the national
party she just gotten there and she was
vice chair of the DNC and then of course
the media played its prescribed role if
Nancy Pelosi likes you well so do they
so fawning profile after fawning profile
emerged if you lived in Washington at
the time you remember it very well here
ladies and gentlemen the future of the
democratic party Tulsi gabbard in case
you don't remember here's a selection to
jog your memory
watch out for the next Superstar
Tulsi gabbard Tulsi gabbard is a rising
star in this party uh Tulsi gabbard
should be here tonight the reality is we
do not have enough Young Veterans in
this party enough young women in this
party enough people calling this party
you're considered a rising star on the
Democratic party you had a position of
leadership in the Democratic National
Committee tulsi's story is really I
think Taylor Made for Hollywood I half
expect Natalie Portman to be vying for
the role any day now because this story
is not to be believed Tulsi gabri is
going to be the one to watch tonight at
the DNC and Tulsa gabbard she's an Iraq
war veteran yesterday she was promoted
from Captain to major in the Hawaii
National Guard so she certainly is a
rising star of the fact that she's not
here tonight for whatever reason is I
don't know but in a battle I want her in
my trench me too me too
did you hear that she's a rising star
Hollywood's gonna make a movie about her
I want her in my Trench
it's pretty hard to believe now but that
was the absolute consensus among
Democratic party sycophants until 2016.
in 2016 as if by command from above the
fawning stopped abruptly replaced
initially by silence and then by howls
of scorned rage
so what happened in 2016 well Donald
Trump was elected president
and then a few days later displaying the
independence of spirit that Democrats
claim to love in young women but
actually despise more than anything
Tulsi Gabbert decided to talk to the new
president about an issue that she cared
about which was U.S policy towards Syria
a country that again gabbard was
virtually alone in pointing out has an
awful lot of Christians in it so maybe
we should pay attention
as she put it at the time quote I felt
it was important to take the opportunity
to meet with the president-elect now
before the drum beats of war that
neocons have been beating drag us into
an escalation of the war to overthrow
the Syrian government
we can't say that in Washington maybe
she didn't know but they told her stop
let the adults do it but gabbard didn't
seem to care a few weeks later she went
personally to Syria she was a member of
Congress you can do that and she wanted
to see conditions for herself and then
while she was there she met with the
Syrian president Bashar al-assad
that was it it was over
whether Tulsi gabbard knew it or not her
career is a rising star within the
Democratic party came to a complete
abrupt and final halt
she had done the one thing you're not
allowed to do she came into the one
unforgivable sin which is to question
permanent Washington's foreign policy
you can't do that and everyone knows it
and if you look around you can see that
no one does do it they always tell you a
radical Sandy Cortez's Rashida Talib
would they do that no way
AOC may be a socialist but in the end
she's with Bill Crystal and Liz Cheney
on team Raytheon
she does not cross that line because
you're not allowed to
but Tulsi gabbard is someone who had
served in the US military in fact was
still serving in the U.S military was an
elected member of Congress decided why
shouldn't I say what I think and so she
did and for doing that overnight her
fellow Democrats accused Tulsi gabbard
the combat veteran you'd want in your
Foxhole
of committing treason against the
country she was serving
Hillary Clinton went even farther than
that speaking of conspiracy nuts Hillary
Clinton Way crazier than Alex Jones ever
thought of being she claimed the
Russians were grooming Tulsi gabbard as
some kind of Manchurian Candidate you
want to listen to lunacy listen to this
I'm not making any predictions but I
think they've got their eye on somebody
who's currently in the Democratic
primary and are grooming her to be the
third party candidate she's a favorite
of the Russians
well that's just completely whacked was
she a crisis actor too what a lunatic
but no one noticed because everyone was
saying it the LA Times which at one
point was an actual newspaper accused
Tulsi gabbard of quote talking like a
Russian asset maybe a spy
so the years went by and Chelsea gabbard
decided to run for president still as a
Democrat as she had been
in her entire time in Congress she'd
always been a Democrat of course the
vice chair of the DNC
and so she went up in a presidential
debate in October of 2019 and she
responded to the smears against her
watch this
New York Times and CNN have also smeared
veterans like myself for calling for an
end to this regime change War just two
days ago the New York Times put out a an
article saying that I'm a Russian asset
and an Assad apologist and all these
different smears this morning a CNN
commentator said on National Television
that I'm an asset of Russia completely
despicable
as president I will end these regime
change Wars by doing two things
ending the Draconian sanctions that are
really a modern day Siege the likes of
which we are seeing Saudi Arabia wage
against Yemen that have caused tens and
thousands of Syrian civilians to die and
to starve and I would make sure that we
stop supporting terrorists like Al Qaeda
in Syria who've been the ground force in
this ongoing regime change War
they called her a Russian asset now that
slur is so common that we don't really
think about it but think about it just
for a second this is a transparently
patriotic person an elected member of
Congress who was serving in the U.S army
who's also by the way one of the nicest
people in all of Washington who is
making traditionally liberal points
about war not that all wars are bad or
war is never necessary
she's participated in Wars personally
she's merely saying and has said dozens
of times on television that words that
don't benefit the United States are
probably a bad idea for us to engage in
that's all she said
and for that she was run out of town now
why is that why is that such an
unacceptable thing to say well of course
because there's a pattern here certain
people do benefit from Wars and they
want more so three years after that
debate
another U.S funded regime change war is
underway and that is exactly what's
happening this time our stated goal is
removing not some third world dictator
who might have wmd but removing a guy
who was the world's largest nuclear
stockpile 6 300 nuclear warheads
Vladimir Putin
and once again because Tulsi gabbard has
questioned the wisdom of this complete
lunacy Democrats are accusing her of
working for Vladimir Putin so if you
want to know what the Democratic party
actually believes don't listen to what
they say oh we want empowered women of
color who are also veterans no they
don't
they want people who support regime
change War that's their red line that's
the one thing they will Brook no dissent
on whatsoever
they don't care what you think about
that
they don't
want to debate you on it
if you disagree or even ask questions
they go right to Trader
so today Tulsi gabber did what is
probably inevitable and probably has
been since 2016 she left her own party
the Democratic party we don't have to
guess as to why because she explained it
in some detail and we ask you please
listen carefully to this because it's
inspiring and interesting and she did it
on her new podcast called the Tulsi
gabbard show it launched today here she
is
I can no longer remain in today's
Democratic party it's now under the
complete control of an elitist cabal of
War mongers driven by cowardly wokeness
who divide Us by racializing every issue
and stoking anti-white racism
who actively work to undermine our
god-given freedoms enshrined in our
constitution
and who are hostile to people of faith
and spirituality
who demonize the police who protect
criminals at the expense of law-abiding
Americans
who believe in open borders who
weaponize the National Security State to
go after their political opponents and
above all
are dragging us ever closer to nuclear
war
now these are some of the main reasons
I'm leaving the Democratic Party
so keep in mind until today this was a
registered Democrat an office holder a
standard bearer of the democratic party
the future of the democratic party from
the country's most liberal State this
was a liberal Democrat
did you hear that is there a single word
you disagree with is there a single word
that the Republican who represents you
who you send money to who you vote for
would repeat in public in other words
here you have someone who until
yesterday was remember the Democratic
party saying things the overwhelming
majority of Republican voters believe
but only a tiny a vanishingly small
minority of Republican office holders
are willing to say out loud because it's
too scary
oh it just tells you so much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight